alphonse daudet entreprend son roman
jack témoignage sans concession d'une
époque chronique sociale impitoyable
dans ce drame d'un enfant il brasse
toutes les douleurs de sa propre
jeunesse les hommes et les lieux qu'il
décrit il les a connu comme écrivain
journaliste et surtout enquêteurs tout
ce qu'il dit a été
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
te croque dans un luxueux hôtel
particulier du boulevard des italiens
jacques mène une vie heureuse auprès de
sa mère ida de barran si jamais il n'a
été séparé d'elle pourtant tandis qu'il
joue seul avec des amis imaginaires
là haut dans le boudoir bon ami exerce
tout son autorité youpi youpi
oui mais voilà
[Musique]
avec des chars et ses grands déjà très
grand les faits voyez-vous pourquoi il
est important pour lui qu'il aille dans
cette institution
oui alors directement
c'est bien de lui n'oubliez pas que nous
partons la semaine prochaine c est ce si
difficile parce que difficile ne vous
fait pas un monde d'une chose aussi
simple et c'est voulu parier
jack jack
jack
tu as que
[Musique]
ce coup
sa poule à peu et ses filles vie
d'adélaïde de l'alcool willem est
constant fait pas puisque c'est l'alcool
oui ce qu'il aurait pu se tuer deux
jours ont donné bien c'est fini
maintenant cessé de respirer vous allez
l'étouffer non c'est pas le mien j'ai vu
une ravissante robe billets et consorts
une robe en histoires merveilleuses
je suis sûr qu'à m'ira très bien parlé
un petit peu tous les deux que tu
mettras celle ci aussi dans mes bagages
que ça doit être bon venir tu
n'oublieras pas aussi mon costume de
draps en coton j'oublié papillon
tu comprends n'est ce pas mais c'est que
je ne verrai pas maman mais voyons
puisque te dis que tu la verras toutes
les semaines ce n'est pas longue six
jours tous les petits enfants le
tournage monte au collège et puis j
culte où seule la pâture à des familles
du para joue au ballon rond au jeu de
billes tu aime bien jouer aux billes et
si tu travailles bien je t'achèterai la
grande boîte de peinture tête souvient
quelques tu as vu l'autre jour et qui te
plaisait bien
tu sais que ta maman peut être un grand
garçon qui n'a peur de rien ces
papillons est bien plus jolie sur des
verres foncés
n'est ce pas constant oui madame aux jo
on a mis j'ai vu hier j'ai pas lumière
une robe deviner imaginez une soirée
bleuté parsemé de rossa velours noir
c'est tout simplement merveilleux 12
iront ensemble si vous le voulez bien
nous verrons demain
dans ce cas vous irez seul demain je
suis sur la route de tours mais ne
deviez vous fait plus mal
vous êtes et l'ama chez les enfants le
plus courageux du monde c'est vrai alors
c'est d'accord monjack surtout tu ne
pleures rappaz mais l'a promis
vous reviendrez samedi
[Musique]
maman
merci monsieur supérieure pour ce parti
[Musique]
en plus d'un stand
oui on
comment t'appelles-tu chat que monsieur
supérieur ah oui c'est son nom se
prononce en anglais comme ceci chirac
cheney et sikhs et son parrain allocs
mbook était major de l'armée des indes
c'était un onglet au un homme très
distinguée comme vous savez est
parfaitement bien des points d'accès
tarde à venir
il est mort d'une attaque d'une façon
affreuse pas sega pour il ya quelques
années lors d'une d'une magnifique
chasse aux tirs quand rajab est
organisée en son honneur au mieux ce
sont de vrais monarque serradj à celui
là surtout il était très réputé ils
s'étaient commencer petit j'ai son nom
sur le bout de la langue ramadam après
jacques que mes temps nous voyons des
bars ainsi
[Musique]
et c'est aussi le nom de l'enfant
évidemment un
j'ai perdu mon mari il y a dix ans à des
conditions rigoureuses comme seul on
peut vous lui indiquez le code barre
aussi appartenait à l'une des plus
anciennes familles de touraine
[Musique]
le tour est dit tout
hu
[Musique]
on est premier set en forme en tribunes
au jardin oui vous ceci s'ennuie un peu
alors retrouvé ta mère ici dans quelques
instants
ben mon chéri obéit à monsieur
cet enfant vous aime beaucoup madame
et comme on aimerait t-il pas il n'y a
que moi au monde
ne croyez-vous pas que notre institution
soit bien austère pour lui me paraît un
peu fragile vous trompez jack est très
robuste il n'a jamais été malade au
dortoir son plein la saison scolaire est
déjà très avancé nous avons dû renvoyer
de nouveaux élèves pour la rentrée
prochaine
ainsi vous refuser d'admettre mon fils
me dit rêve au moins la raison
voilà je vous en prie
[Musique]
ne me faites pas m'expliquer davantage
je n'ai le droit de rien vous demandez
je regrette
supérieur
je ne vous ai pas dit la vérité
et je ne pouvais pas mon nom et celui
d'une des plus anciennes familles de
france et je mourrai plutôt que le
divulguer l'open book aurait tellement
souhaité que jack reçoivent une
éducation aristocratique et chrétienne
digne du grand nom qu'il porte
il faudra donc je sois victime d'une
fatalité inouïe votre petit jacques me
plaît beaucoup madame jeu qu'on sera le
recevoir parmi nos élèves à monsieur
supérieur à une condition c'est que pour
le voir
regardez ici dans mon bureau une fois
par mois
et pourquoi pas au parloir comme tout le
monde et tous les jeudis
je pense que mon enfant on se fait les
parents de nos élèves
[Musique]
pauvre enfant
jack
viens nous partons
[Musique]
à la maison vite mal team tech chez
renault où la musique est pour dire nous
comprendrons chez inutile mais je me
verrais mal en seconde et qui finit une
porte plus mais ce que je pleure moi et
l'on parle de moi
qu'est ce que tu dis moi je veux et rien
qu'à moi tu sais ce qu'ils voulaient que
je ne peux pas parce que jamais mais je
ne vais pas tous les jours de ma vie du
couple saluera nîmes ont tout de suite
notre dame or si nous nous arrêtions mot
clé est la pâtisserie espagnol tu es
content je crois oui maman rencontre des
comtesses et du cese on était mieux à la
campagne athée parce que tu t'es mon
chéri je suis sûr qu'il y aura la
princesse de monthois maman tu disais je
veux bien les bâches ici il n'y en a pas
mais paris jack c'est pour j'enverrai
encore mais de quoi parle-t-on mon chéri
regard c'est magnifique
oui maman on va le masque et j'allais
oublier augusta vite à la maison mesure
vient droit cette pâtisserie c'est
promis et que je me prépare pour le bail
tu comprends oui mon nom ne dit pas à
bonn et demi que je fais à spa ce sera
un secret entre nous d
eh bien mon jack aspar de balles de
gomme masqué tapiero chanter
chanter danser dans ce beau c'est niso
des mots d'amour
tvo passait bien
vidéo
étant
mon cher pierrot
oui
tout ça
cette nuit
allons allons à ces défis sillage vous
mettre en retard voila voila tu seras
bien sage et demain nous irons au bois
tu mois contrats tombant le masque et
promis de négocier dia
aux forces et vous un peu monsieur jack
allez prenez votre assiette
[Musique]
si ça s'est mal passé c'est que ce
prêtre n'a pas eu confiance est la base
du savoir s'y prendre
ah oui la journée a été plutôt mauvaise
voie après la pluie le beau temps
il ya des gens comme ça qui change tout
de suite le mauvais l'image tant mieux
qu'il soit encore ici ce petit pourquoi
vous ne compreniez pas mes explications
monsieur jacques c'était très bien qu'il
rentre chez les pères il était gentil
oui tous étaient gentils oui mais quand
même vous auriez été moins bien ici ou
ceux qui ont juste pas pareil moi qu'est
ce que vous voulez et quand je vois un
si petit comme ça enfermé tout jeune ça
me fait quelque chose et vous vous dites
autre chose ça ne mange rien
et forcément c'est toujours garé de
gâteaux en attendant je me demande ce
que sa mère va bien pouvoir faire
les enfants c'est pour être avec les
parents il est bien ici et bien moi je
ne trouve pas niveau plus devenu
français
alors d'après vous c'est sale et une vie
familiale en leur dos la nhtsa soient
bien il ya façon et façon d'aimer moi si
j'avais un fils je sais bien ce que je
fais mais parfaitement gustin je le sais
ils abhorrent il sera pension mais c'est
ce qu'elle a voulu fait non mais
justement non quand on a la folie des
grandeurs on voit ce qu'il vous arrive
d'ailleurs à partir de demain je m'en
occupe et je serai choisir moi de mon
temps quand j'allais à l'école et colle
parfaitement
j'ai eu mon certificat d'études doura
comme je suis vivant ici devant vous
qu'est ce que c'est le certificat le
certificat d'études et vous pour vous
qu'est ce que c'est une pension une
pension d'études et même que j'en
connais une et une fameuse vous oui moi
parfaitement mois le gymnase moronval
quand j'étais chemise egypte
c'est là que je conduisais le petit saïd
et même que le directeur qui dirige tout
ça il me donnait des prospectus en veux
tu en voilà
pour que les distribuer aux ami son
excellence alors vous en avez de ses
prospectus
ouais je vais chercher même qui faisait
la réclame dans les gazettes procurer
m'ennuie le plus vite sera le mieux j'en
parlerai à madame dès demain mais tel
que je la connais elle accepte
trop heureuse de se débarrasser d'une
corvée pauvre petit qu'il dort comme un
an à les augustins monté lui dans sa
chambre est dans son lit est 7 heures
[Applaudissements]
e
[Musique]
et
à
[Musique]
et
oh
[Musique]
le
et
j'ai pas arrêté dans ces mondes jacques
c'était merveilleux suis épuisée mais
heureuse au
d'ange bonne nuit moment bail
adam
ana
madame
et 11 heures on essayages canton veille
on dort et vous pouvez y aller ça tape
une idée de jack dans le jardin
justement je voulais vous parler ce
qu'il fait je ne sais pas d'où est ce
que tu as j'ai jugé
vous m'avez chargé de trouver pour
monsieur jack
en vous n'aurait encore rien manger
constants si tu savais le succès que
j'ai eu à ce bal masqué cette nuit j'ai
rencontré la duchesse de marjo elle
était un avis de marthe is pas bien du
tout on s'est heurtés toutes les deux et
elle m'a dit keith vous mais quand je le
lui ai dit elle était enchantée
j'ai trouvé pour monsieur nous avons
rendez-vous de 20 la pâtisserie espagnol
constant du mois willy sujet lit bien
sûr que vous êtes jolie chérie
entendre cela s'en ressent pas pendant
toute une soirée
c'est grisant j'ai trouvé une école pour
monsieur jack
pourquoi ne la tue pas du tout de suite
c'est parce qu'on a parlé d'autre chose
alors évidemment il paraît que c'est
très très bien
gymnase moronval dans le plus beaux
quartiers de paris
grands jardins nombre d'infos limiter ou
de prononciation française par la
méthode moronval koster rectification
d'accent lecture expressive à haute voix
par configuration des mots il y à même
le fils d'une excellence mais c'est
merveilleux
tu vas y aller moi oui toi bobigny tu
comprends je ne veux plus avoir affaire
à ces sortes de gens yara vaugirard
helmand troupe humilié je ne veux plus
je veux faire du mal bonbons gérer
puisque vous vous rendez malade pour
rien puis tu tu verras si jack peut-être
rue dans cette pension tu regarderas
bien tout n'est ce pas constante tu
promets oui
mon petit monsieur jack
monsieur de chasse et vous refuser
d'aller cette école je veux dire aux
gendarmes
oui si c'était le mien
quelle école tosetto policy une
institution très élégant tu va beaucoup
apprendre
pkoi tu seras grand tu verras dans les
plus grands salons tu connaîtras des
gens très célèbre et c'est heureux oui
mon nom c'est très bon chat bon rat tout
de suite et vous vous ne mangez pas ça
parce tard croyable c'est à se demander
comment votre époux
mademoiselle conservateur conduira cette
école mon chéri tu deviens pas vécu un
moment non j'ai un essai gages
importants faut absolument que j'y gagne
puis quand on est un grand garçon comme
toi augustin sorti la voiture madame tu
te tiendra pire tu seras bien sa
jeunesse pas me chercher
qui prendra bien soin de ville costa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ginès mon combat c'est bien ici
[Applaudissements]
que se passe-t-il
mamadou voilà si monsieur mourad
il a dit de faire du feu pour la dame et
le petit bisou mafate
madame moronval de koster en trois mots
de koster
quel beau aux yeux tout à fait les yeux
de sa mère
c'est pas ma mère si la bonne non je
suis la gouvernante
alors voyons chère madame que voulez
vous de moi vous êtes bien le directeur
du gymnase mort vague qui est annoncée
dans le journal illustré oui oui
parfaitement
un élève mon dieu le bel enfant madame
m'a chargé de trouver une pension pour
monsieur jack
alors je voudrais savoir si vous avez
une place ici pour lui et quels sont vos
conditions parce que madame m'a dit tout
ce que vous free sera bien fait mais je
comprends je comprend enfin je veux dire
nous comprenons c'est un vrai malheur
madame est très très elle ne suit que
son plaisir dans cette un malheur parce
que quand on a un enfant on se doit
d'être sérieux mais ça ça lui passe au
dessus de la tête
nous vous aiderons madame marois il le
four et puis s'il n'y avait que ça mais
madame sort beaucoup
évidemment avec le monde quelle façon
c'est une comtesse qui nous vaut tous
deux fait une comtesse elle rentre le
soir très tard le matin elle dort au
petit la voit jamais tu sais pas nos
vies voilà pourquoi il a besoin de vous
ah oui
c'est une tâche sublime que nous
acceptons d'un grand coeur que de
pallier la carence et l'incurie de ceux
qui n'ont pas la force d'avoir le
courage ya la pension se pressent pas
3000 francs sorte rousseau naturel l'on
sait peut-être un peu cher non non non
c'est très bien d'ailleurs
non mais qui est attaché à notre
institution pourra constituer les fronts
il avait d'ailleurs elle amador la coupe
anglaise et maintenant laissez moi vous
expliquer ce que mon école c'était le
gymnase le seul digne de ce nom
un allemand d'ailleurs guy mena zoom et
si madame c'est un lieu de libre
exercice pour l'esprit le corps il faut
du grec et du latin mais pas trop il
faut aussi les vertus profonde
développées j'ai noté élèves des
sentiments humains
la douceur de la vie de famille j'ai
beaucoup d'étrangers loin de chez eux
il faut de la chaleur beaucoup de
chaleur vous comprenez madame et c'est
pourquoi en vertu des besoins de l'âme
enfantine
j'ai voulu comment gymnase soit leur
image calme douceur rêve dont le même
temps qu'ils travaillent parce que j'ai
des professeurs éminents et qu'il soir
on met nos enfants théâtre dans le monde
car je veux je veux je soutient qu'une
tête bien faite vaut mieux qu'une tête
bien pleine
comme monsieur jack sera bien chez vous
cela vous pouvez être tranquille
nous n'avons d'ailleurs que des
étrangers de distinction tous noble
j'ai même un enfant de son royal fils de
roi un fils de moi vous entendez
monsieur jack
vous serez élevé avec un fils de roi
j'en ai fait un homme faut dire un
moment de venir
mais monsieur jack mais laissez moi
finir
vous payez un trimestre à lens cela me
presse pas voyons un merci monsieur les
bons comptes font les bons amis
le tailleur lui par contre ne saurait
attendre trois bateaux sur moi pensant
huit fois lors juste et élèves dont la
part dieu où l'attend 3 - alors va bien
toujours aussi maladroit mais ces
commissions yeux du feu
je vous présente monsieur la basse indre
notre professeur de chant monsieur
là-bas sein de l'académie matériel de
musique à ce propos
dois-je inscrire l'enfant pour deux
chambres il n'en coûte que 500 francs au
bien sûr qu'elles sont mots jacques de
baroncelli jacques de balancer dans la
set list jacques devancé jack avec un c
est un cas sa mairie tient avec un saut
j'ai osé voilà et 500 francs
et sauvage naît ou neuf ans je ne sais
pas où il est né fait madame vous le
dira eh bien vous voici inscrits
monsieur de balancer dans une école qui
peuvent s'enorgueillir les plus grands
succès madame je suis votre serviteur
enfin lussier nous allons ajouter
monsieur dia japonais jusqu'à la grille
mais oui mais oui c'est le moment de
faire les comptes
monsieur la gardienne va non seulement
ça ne voyez pas mais on va voir si je
mettais 4 goudal camille sée exploserait
plus explosif ça y est ils sont l'argent
qu'il est moral et ça va nous passer
sous le nez des venets ils ont de
l'argent il faut se faire payer tout de
suite
alors ça y est ils ont réussi à se faire
exproprier j'ai toujours dit que c'était
sa seule chance d'éviter la faillite est
réduit alors on y va
les éléphantes arrivé exactement mais ne
gérons pas l'expérience
c'était un répulsif qui allait et qui
pouvait mener
j'ai prévenu d'argenton il doit sûrement
se faire payer lui oui mais
allons allons bien martin
[Musique]
oui mais
tu vas tu as vu tu es tu verras
tout ça va passer avoir des petits
camarades et tu seras aussi bien que
cette année
et vous
les joueurs
[Musique]
et
à
lee
monsieur
[Musique]
j'ai trois mois ça dure alors les
promesses monsieur d'argent non non non
ça ne se passera pas comme ça mais vous
mon dieu je suis à la tortue je ne vis
pas de l'air du temps moi ce qui est de
la torture c'est surtout mon estomac est
un mac os j'oubliais la méthode de
prononciation la configuration des mots
est scrap parfaitement les bons comptes
font les bons amis
et maintenant que vous voilà enfin il
prend bien finir le mandat de voilà
qu'est ce qui se passe comme si tu ne le
savais pas le bel étonnement dans ce qui
se passe c'est simple on veut notre
argent ça se comprend vous pensez ça
fait les manchettes au nez rouge est à 6
heures et maintenant écoutez moi
approchez vous approchez vous je le sais
c'est entendu je vous dois de l'argent
mais vous connaissez la situation non
alors parce qu'ils ont été tous réglés
vous le savez mais puisque je n'ai pas
peur et exproprié or il suffit chat
docteur le seul à nous expliquer
l'inexplicable
il m'avait pourtant promis que je serai
expropriés j'ai acheté pour cela le
terrain où devait passer la venue
aujourd'hui je le sens c'est le début de
grandes espérances
ce petit bar ans il va nous faire
revivre je le sens de barran si le fils
d'une comtesse qui ne l'est pas
d'où si je comprends bien viendront pour
nous des subsides plus substantielles
alors alors nous renvoie alors boron
valent 3 lui à chacun pour commencer la
semaine prochaine autant que ça vous va
elle ne m'a payé qu'un trimestre avance
plus les leçons de chant bien je vais
fermer la boîte ont fait mauvais usage
de notre attachement à une oeuvre aussi
sublime que celle ci pour toi louis
et maintenant à l'endroit ce petit
imbécile erreur un imbécile n'est jamais
un imbécile temps qu'il vous est utile
on la presta le souper et de surcroît
fume roussety 16b trois génisses
c'est fini alors au lit
[Musique]
je vous présente jack de balancer on met
le vam antilles
madou finir allez-vous autres à table
madou alors et ça on aime moi ça y est
voilà
[Musique]
tu resteras dans la cheminée le bois qui
n'a pas brûlé
il est interdit de parler dans le
dortoir que je ne l'aurais pas une porte
à les saillies bien m'aider
la voilà ça c'est votre place vous allez
être bien mon petit déshabillé vous là
qu'est ce que c'est que ce bruit
ce sont les chevaux d'un côté un jeu ils
vont faire craquer la toison et alors il
sort dans cette chambre sur ton lit on
va enfin se fait sur ton lit n'ai pas
peur c'est eux le soirs pareil
sa cible
[Musique]
temps
[Applaudissements]
dans mes 1 messieurs je ne peux pas
écouter
c'est dans une grande salle de bal et ça
chante toute la nuit
moi j'aime la musique c'est bon soupire
et quand on a dit chan
si on pouvait pas se leurrer peut-être
qu'on est tous frères chez moi il ya de
la musique et en danse la nuit vous
coucher comme ça sandra c'est ainsi bull
pour moi je dis monsieur mon envie
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est cette médaille c'est
un grigri ckoi et gris gré c'est pour me
porter bonheur
c'est ma tante qu'erica qu'elle ne
l'admets je vais la revoir un jour ma
tante ou aussi je vais revoir moment
c'est beau ton pays
oh oui comment ça s'appelle du dahomey
mais alors tu connais qui met son
altesse royale c'est moi comment ça se
fait ce fait je suis tu veux pas me dire
pourquoi tu est roi c'est mon père
queyroy alors monsieur mort en vain il a
dit que j'étais altesse royale mais
pourquoi tu balaye tu fais la vaisselle
ici dieu comme un domestique
parce que mon père a fait un gain et on
lui a pris son pays après il n'avait
plus d'argent alors monsieur moronval il
a dit que je n'étais plus altesse royale
et que je devais travailler et moi je ne
voulais pas alors il m'a battu il t'a
battu mais quand je rentre dans mon pays
j'ai dû devenir et je lui coupe la tête
comment tu t'appelles jack et opératoire
il est mort tu veux être mon ami
oui alors embrassés et tuera du bonheur
maintenant tu es mon ami
ça plaira cma du matin et on avait un
palais avec de leur parti des éléphants
aussi il faisait la guerre et puis
quelques fois ma tante qu'eric a même
amené sur un cheval très loin dans la
savane c'est si beau la savane ce n'est
pas possible de bien te dire il ya des
couleurs partout du rose du vert de leur
pose aussi des singes noire des
panthères des lions ce que je préférais
c'était des petits du lion tu sais une
joue comme des chats y en avait plein
dans notre panel je t'en donnera à
l'étudiant quand je rentrerai chez moi
parce que maintenant tu es mon ami tu
dors
ça ne tient rien
quand j'entends chez moi je dirai à mon
père que tu viennes
[Musique]
à
et
[Musique]